avant de parler de repérer deux marques
d'hôtels le dossier air france avait
également le dossier air france le
comité central d'entreprise s'est réuni
hier a confirmé la suppression de 1000
postes pour l'année 2016 est ce que la
france est en train de mourir car
laurent la politique qui est menée par
le gouvernement et par là qui est
actionnaire l'état est actionnaire d'air
france et par la direction d'air france
et ses actionnaires
mais la compagnie dans une très grande
difficulté oui et si nous continuons
avec les saignées d'emploi successifs
parce que je rappelle qu'air france a
déjà supprimé plus de 10000 emplois que
là ils en auront au moins encore trois
ou quatre mille sur la sellette et que
déjà alors qu'on a room et même pas en
of saudi qu'il en faudra peut-être doute
donc ce sont les politiques actuellement
menées qui sont en train de saigner la
compagnie est fière moi j'étais avec les
salariés présents devant le ce lieu très
sécurisé il y à il y a une chose a
souligné contrairement à ce qu'a dit le
gouvernement à ce qu'a répété manuel
valls à deux reprises dans l'hémicycle
parce qu'ils essayent d'opposer les
catégories personnel entre entre elles
hier il y avait l'intersyndicale dont
tout le monde était là
les personnels au sol les personnels
navigants et les pilotes le dire ils
sont tous unis pour refuser le plan
actuel donc ça n'est pas ce n'est pas en
nous posant les catégories de personnel
ils posent tous la même question qui est
la question de l'avenir de l'entreprise
et il ya d'autre choix à faire cette
semaine vous avez annoncé votre tête de
liste pour les régionales en île de
france
parmi elles julie morel qui est agent au
sol à air france à l'instar des têtes de
liste dans le val d'oise
elle fait partie du cce qui s'est réuni
hier
est ce que vous aviez prévu de
l'investir avant l'explosion de la crise
air france
il ya quelque chose que nous avions
prévu dès le début dès la constitution
de la lys et de faire de cette liste une
liste où nous nous ouvrions plus de 30%
des candidatures à des candidatures ici
du mouvement social associatif etc etc
c'est le cas la liste que nous allons
déposer officiellement le 2 novembre
comportera 30 % de salariés nous avons
fait une conférence de presse avec une
vingtaine d'entre eux l'autre jour il ya
donc des salariés tous les secteurs et
donc sur air france faisait partie
faisait partie
entreprise où nous avions demandé à ddd
salariés investi dans le conflit de ça
avant avant les événements du 5 octobre
je vous signale parce que ça n'intéresse
pas les médias mais que j'étais à roissy
le 23 septembre pour une initiative avec
les salariés à l'invitation des
organisations syndicales pour parler en
l'occurrence les syndicats la journée du
5 octobre vous l'utilisez politiquement
on a vu éclore sur internet des visuels
qui sont diffusées par le front de
gauche notamment un visuel avec une
chemise patron à découper soi même qui
est une référence évidente à la chemise
du drh da france n'est même fait des
clips vidéo est ce que vous n'avez pas
un peu l'impression de d'exploiter
politiquement des écoutes et social ces
il nous nous exprimons sur sur ce
conflit comme absolument l'ensemble des
transactions de biens légitimes je
rappelle les assurances visuels de
colère france est le premier employeur
privé en ile de france
moi je conduis une liste en île de
france et bien effectivement l'avenir
d'air france avec deux grandes zones
aéroportuaires dans la région ça
m'intéresse et un emploi à air france
ces 4 ou 5 1 points et induit donc c'est
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
de familles qui sont concernées par
l'avenir d'air france donc que cette
question là soit au coeur de ce que nous
portons avec l'autriche et not least
c'est à dire une minute sur la campagne
des régionales sur la campagne des
régionales
vous savez qu'il faut atteindre 10%
pouvoir se maintenir au second tour est
ce que vous y croyez ce que vous pensez
que vous allez pouvoir atteindre cette
légende symbolique jeu je travaille pour
ça évidemment si je conduis une liste
avec l'ambition même de présider la
région si c'est possible c'est parce que
nous avons des idées en matière de
transport de logement de rééquilibrage
d'emploi de développement économique de
lutte contre la pollution
nous avons un programme qui est
parfaitement crédible nous avons occupé
des responsabilités dans la région donc
effectivement moi je travaille à mettre
cette liste le plus haut possible si
vous obtenez 10% vous allez vous
maintenir face à claude bartolone qui a
priori les obtiendra aussi mais écoutez
moi dans la région
il n'y a pas que c'est pas un face à
face enfin moins que les autres listes
se retire pour la situation c'est pas en
face à face entre claude bartolone et
pierre leroux
il ya d'autres listes à ma connaissance
donc moi je veux battre le front
national et la droite dans cette région
vous savez je suis conseiller régional
et valérie pécresse l'était donc dans
dans la région je les ai toujours eu en
face de moi à chaque fois que j'ai
proposé deux mesures sociales valérie
pécresse l'a combattaient alors je vais
pas la laisser
donc moi je veut effectivement
travailler à une victoire de gauche mais
pour des politiques de gauche offensive
et je compte pour ça sur le fait que ma
liste arrive le plus haut possible et si
possible en tête
eh bien merci pierre laurent d'avoir été
les nôtres à vitré merci jean